Catherines Beck is professor of art
history and coordinator of postgraduate
programs in art history and curatorial
and Museum Studies at the University of
Adelaide and the art gallery of South
Australia her publications include
painting ghosts Australian women artists
in wartime and hessen and hessen
selected letters of ha of Hans hessen
and Nora hessen and most recently beyond
the battlefield women artists in the two
world wars she is also the author of
numerous articles on Australian art and
a co researcher on an Australian
Research Council project Australian art
exhibitions 1968 to 2009 which is
exploring how key Australian art
exhibitions prefigure and shape art
history please join me in welcoming
Katherine's fact
do i turn the lights down they'll just
go to ok Britain and America approached
the visual record of the war in
differing ways each being aware of the
employment scheme of artists in times of
national need I'm sorry each being aware
of the others employment schemes of
artists in times of national need this
paper focuses on the to-and-fro of
information about such programs and the
quite different ways each nation
approached employing or commissioning
artists and women in particular so that
there would be a visual record of the
conflict we turn first to Britain prior
to the announcement of war and how Sir
Kenneth Clark the director of London's
National Gallery was already considering
the role of artists in the coming war
everyone considered inevitable uppermost
in his mind was how his country during
the First World War had been slow in
developing a scheme to employ artists
and how some like Henry gardea breske
enlisted and was sent to the front and
subsequently died he was determined that
this time he would employ artists rather
than seeing them caught up he was
familiar with how the American
government during the Depression
commissioned artists on mural projects
like the federal arts project and he
thought that Britain was seventy-three
percent of artists unemployed needed a
similar scheme America meanwhile had no
such thoughts about the role of artists
in wartime Clarke knew he needed to move
quickly by late-september 1939 he
already had a list of 51 male and female
artists who could be employed and he'd
formed a committee for the employment of
artists oh sorry he'd formed a committee
for the employment of artists in wartime
and it had already met by early November
he'd reached agreement with the ministry
of information that the production of
our relating to war should come under
their ministry and and also that on
sixteenth of November Herald Minister
Harold Macmillan a supporter of the Arts
had approved the formation of the war
artists Advisory Committee
the wac that you heard cassia's talk
about the wac was a smooth and effective
committee Kenneth Clark had selected
members carefully with a perceived
balance of tastes and interests and the
three armed services agreed to select
only artists recommended by the WAC
membership of that committee changed
during the war years but Clark remained
the chair and the dominant force and he
gave shape and direction to the WAC that
direction often correspond to the
particular and shifting course of the
war in Britain which was under attack as
we've heard in the previous paper for
much of the time and the public display
of paintings drawings and prints by war
artists was a key morale lifting element
in the total British response to the
wall by the fifteenth of December 1939
the british war art program and what it
would achieve was a subject of a BBC
radio broadcast in which artists are
advised to make contact and they did
thirty-seven artists were subsequently
given full-time commissions just one of
which went to a woman Evelyn Dunbar
Ethel Cobain whose work you see here and
Dorothy coke were also given short-term
contracts and those three appointments
along with that of five male artists
were announced in The Times on the
twenty-fifth of april nineteen forty a
further eight women artists were
eventually given contracts and art was
purchased from 34 others some of whom
are considered in this paper the
employment or the commissioning of women
as war artists in Britain had a history
an aerie was commissioned during the
first war to document the work in
munitions while the Imperial War museums
Director General Sir Martin Conway
nominated and these are his words the
work of women both directly for the war
purpose and indirectly by substitution
as one of its collecting areas right
from the time of the Imperial War Museum
establishment in 1917 clearly in Britain
there were some cognizance of the fact
that while wars then involved male
citizens in warfare this could only
occur with all the material and
emotional support from the home front
and that women assist
nurses and voluntary aides behind the
front so it was not unexpected that
women were appointed or commissioned as
war artists in the second world war in
America meanwhile well before Pearl
Harbor artists arts organizations and
arts publications were already engaging
with the cultural dimensions of the wall
life magazine's editor Henry Luce backed
his country's intervention in the Second
World War and on the seventeenth of
februari 1941 he advocated moving from
its regional and isolationist starts to
one of concern with global issues both
the magazine of art and art News ran
stories on the intersections between art
and war and in June 1941 left-leaning
artists held a symposium in New York on
the need to defend art and culture from
fascism they staged a large rally on the
sixth of June 1941 at the Manhattan
center also in mid nineteen forty one in
reviewing the touring exhibition Britain
of war Britain at war that several of
our speakers have talked about an on
show at mama Margot Varga a regular
writer for the magazine of art wrote
America's artists are as eager to do
their part as Britain's all they need is
a signal from the government in the past
seven years through the program for the
documentation of public buildings
they've brought America closer to the
hearts of the people they stand ready
now while the country needs every
citizens cooperation why has not the
government harness this force to service
in the way it's most needed at this time
now the couldn't the conditions were
very different in each nation but also
and this is the main theme of this paper
the way each government harnessed the
service of its artists and women in
particular differed radically Britain's
artists quickly found themselves in the
middle of a war especially as we've
heard in this last paper from the
seventh of September 1942 the twenty
first of May 1941 Germany inflicted
sustained bombing on highly populated
areas and one in six Londoners lost
their homes and women and children in
the early were vulnerable Britain
mobilized their entire population in
order to survive
and much of the British women's are
commissioned by the wack records these
and other pressing issues realists
lithographer Ethel Cobain was a key
artist in documenting how ordinary
people coped and contributed in a war
being fought on their home front for
instance she was commissioned by the WAC
to document the movement of a hundred
thousand children under 5 and 1 million
school-age children to the safety of the
English countryside where they were
placed in foster homes and here in the
work you see in front of you in the
evacuation of children from Southend
gabon shows each child equipped with
essential supplies these mostly anxious
children were quite unaware they were
part of a well-meaning mass movement
which has been referred to as the
greatest upheaval in modern Britain
Cobain felt that the courage women
showed in keeping up the daily work
while the homefront was being attacked
needed to be documented and in fact she
had to push that point with the whack
and here here in demolition brick
sorting and chipping she shows a group
of women from the Islington borough an
area that suffered much damage they have
the daunting job of turning mountains of
bricks from Braun from bombed buildings
into useful recycled material the
reality of the war on the British Home
Front was that each and every citizen
was involved in some way Evelyn Gibb was
commissioned by the WAC to show how the
women's voluntary service of civil
defense stepped in to assist those who
lost everything in air raids by
supplying garments for people in need
and here in the vws clothing exchange
Gibbs shows two volunteers and their
distinctive green uniforms finding
clothing for women and children in
addition to focusing on the everyday
Ethel Cobain portrayed some of the
heroes such as pilot captain sorry
Carter such as part of a captain Pauline
girl of the Women's Air Transport
auxiliary now girl was particularly
incensed that the
ref wouldn't let women pilots fly planes
so she established a woman's air
transport auxiliary in a TA and they
proceeded to fly planes between Air
Force stations and to deliver newly
built aircraft to their destination they
flew without radio contact and in all
ref plains except the large flying boats
royal academician laura knight was
contracted to and in two instances when
the labor of women was urgently needed
she was commissioned to produce a
painting we're going to consider just
one of those in 1941 when women were
being brought into balloon command the
WAC commissioned laura knight to produce
a painting that would bring in recruits
to work with the barrage balloons these
were balloons filled with helium and
attached to wire cables that rose to a
height of between 7,000 to 10,000 feet
to deter enemy planes as Harold peek
from the air ministry wrote in 1941
although we now have conscription of
women it's not going to be too easy to
get just the right sort of person to opt
for this particular class of work any
picture which will provide useful
publicity for balloon command will be
particularly valuable during the next
two to three months Laura night did just
this and in balloon site Coventry as you
can see she shows the mostly female crew
launching a balloon under the very able
leadership of their female sergeant
another crucial aspect of the war was
food production many farm laborers were
serving in the armed forces and Britain
was no longer able to safely import food
so there was a shift to home production
by the end of 1943 80,000 non-rural
women worked in the Land Army and Evelyn
Dunbar was directed by the WAC to
document this dumb bar was employed
continuously as a war artist until the
war's end and she was based several
agricultural sites including the east
malling fruit research station in kent
land army girls were trained there in
how to prune trees directly and this is
the subject of a painting you see in
front of you a 1944
draw dunbar worked in the near romantic
style in a composition centers around
the striking linear qualities in the
geometric structure that the three
ladders give to the women pruning the
way would limbs it's late autumn the
branches are bare but a sense of fantasy
gives those trees foursome rounded
shapes the enduring cyclical nature of
the activity involving the many gloved
hands wielding pruning shears
secretaries and saws frames the subject
and underscores it as a neo-romantic
pastoral scene so beloved by the British
the subject and how it's depicted
implies continuity and certainty when
the external world offered no such
reassurance while dunbar been busy
covering all aspects of food production
including the new technology in trouble
seeing these including the new
technology of canning in a canning
demonstration the wac had neglected its
focus on nursing lady Louise Mountbatten
the administrator of the Red Cross
pointed this out to Kenneth Clark so
dumb Bart was duly directed to hospital
train 21 one of a fleet of ambulances
sorry one of the fleet of trains
converted two ambulances and designed to
move those injured in air raids from
cities to hospitals or first aid
stations in safer areas and as you can
see here in hospital train she shows to
staff preparing for patients again you
know working in that near of a romantic
style a comforting rendition a train of
10 carriages could carry large numbers
of wound up with 30 patients on a
stretcher / van it meant 300 plus other
sitting injured could be efficiently
moved to safety 500,000 british women
joined the various women's services but
the visual record of this mass movement
in developed into military culture is
extremely slim Stella schmoll who worked
as a drafts woman and then in
intelligence in the 80s in France and
then in Brussels completed numerous
paintings of 80s mechanics drivers and
cooks such as the dough room that you
see
here while Dorothy Koch was one of the
few British artists committed a
commission to record the way sorry to
record the web service women and the 80s
service women on the home front but
really the wac just did not follow that
particular part of the war ever so we've
looked briefly about some of the british
women recorded and how the wac oversaw
appointments and choice of subject
matter we turn now to the united states
who as we know into the war in december
1941 the US government's cultural
response was never on the scale of
britain America in contrast to Britain
didn't have a record of employing or
commissioning women as war artists the
eight the war artist appointed as
official artists in the American
Expeditionary Forces in the first war to
go to France to document the American
contribution were all men their
representational focus thus was entirely
masculine despite the fact that America
sent large numbers of nurses to France
in that war one of the first changes on
the American Home Front in February 1942
was to declare japanese-americans
displaced persons and to move them into
internment camps in northern california
this prompted the War Relocation
administration of the Office of War
Information the OWI to Commission to
photo artists Dorothea Lange and Ansel
Adams to document him Dorothea Lange you
a good number of the japanese-americans
and she felt the injustice of the
situation deeply her photograph that you
can see here of the 13th of March 1942 I
am an American shows a local landmark
cuantos grocery fruit and vegetable shop
which was forced to close due to the
owners internment on the day the
Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor mr. wanto
felt it necessary to put up a sign as
you can see here i am an American
proclaiming his American citizenship
other photographs like members of the
machida family awaiting their evacuation
bus show the patients and the quiet
dignity of the dispossessed
and then wearing name tags as you can
see to issue to keep families together
laying visited almost all of the 21
camps where those interns were placed
she found people living in very poor
conditions and with little privacy her
officially commissioned photographs were
not released though until after the war
was over America was particularly slow
in forming an army art unit this
occurred in 1943 principally because the
Assistant Secretary of War John McCloy
could see that the Navy with its eight
active duty male artists was the only
service visually documenting the wall he
called in artist George Biddle a former
First World War army staff officer and
well-connected politically within a
short space of time the Army Corps of
Engineers who'd run that combat art
program are referred to in the First
World War established an army art unit
in February 1943 under Biddle's
leadership an initial list was drawn up
of 41 male artist correspondence 23 of
whom were already serving and 19
civilians this list was extended to 59
artists and only three were women Marion
Greenwood luchia Wally and Doris
Rosenthal Greenwood was trying to have
more women employed she sent George
Biddle a list of 20 women including
Peggy bacon Doris Lee and Minister trong
she followed this up with a letter to
mrs. henry morgenthau jr. of the
Treasury Department's section of Fine
Arts Committee writing a considerable
number of men artists are already being
used to depict the war both at home and
abroad now a group of women artists
including myself are trying to establish
themselves on the same basis three women
have been chosen to work on the
homefront but considering the tremendous
scope of war activities and the large
number of women artists available we
feel their employment should be greatly
expanded meanwhile by March 1943 male
artists from the army art unit started
arriving in combat zones however Biddle
was not the best ambassador for the
program and funding was withdrawn by
Congress in August 43 as we heard
yesterday
by June 44 the active-duty artists were
reinstated under the arm of the Army's
historical division thus affirming its
male artists only orientation the
civilian women artists including luchia
Wiley and Doris Rosenthal were never
contracted and Marion Greenwoods idea to
employ more women failed to eventuate
Marion Greenwood meanwhile was taken on
by abbott laboratories as a war artist
in nineteen 44 and 45 this chicago-based
pharmaceutical company had reached an
agreement with the american government
in 1943 that they would sponsor the
collection of saris they would sponsor
the formation of an art collection that
would serve as a comprehensive record of
war activities and that the collection
would become the property of the US
government Abbott Laboratories agreed to
cover all the costs and the expenses
while the associated American artists
nominated the artists and helped
administer the scheme the War Department
provided transport and housing Greenwood
was the only woman serving as a war
artist under this scheme and she was
based at the Army Medical Department
England General Hospital in Atlantic
City Atlantic City New Jersey her
assignment was to document the medical
treatment and the rehabilitation of ink
of injured soldiers from the European
and the pacific war zones who works
include her tender study you see here in
front of you Brooklyn kid from Anzio
showing a young soldier whose eyes have
a sadness that doesn't max match his age
and exercise period for the wounded
Greenwald was a highly regarded mural
artist who'd worked in Mexico at the
invitation of Diego Rivera and she was
well versed in presenting dynamic group
compositions but here as you see
suggesting bodily repair Life magazine
as we've heard in a few papers during
the symposium was also commissioning
paintings of American involvement at the
front and at home for their wartime
issues modernist painter Edna Randall
could envisage how Californian women
workers at the lockheed aircraft factory
and at the Cal ship shipbuilding yards
would make ideal subject
so she approached the magazine
editor-in-chief Daniel long will liked
the idea life too was in the process of
developing an art collection documenting
the war and she was advised that her
paintings would enter that collection
Randall's paintings were reproduced in
Life Magazine on the fifth of jun 1944
one day prior to d-day they appeared as
a photo essay and contained images of
the artist sketching her subjects and so
the photographs underscoring the
documentary nature of the assignment
Randall worked in the style of magic
realism and as you see here in Cal ship
burnin she shows rosemary Wiley using
her oxygen oxygen torch with extreme
care to trim in excess strip of metal
from a piece of steel destined to become
part of the ship's body the impact of
the image in life lies not just in its
visual qualities though typical of the
magic realist style but it's combination
of image and text the magazine bureau
was liaising with the major magazines
based in you in New York and they
published a language guide war jobs for
women the text was closely aligned with
the direction of the American
governments campaign around women in war
and when the photo essay appeared in
life it did so under the header women at
war the text informed the reader that
rosemary while he was a former
University student she'd since married
works the midnight to morning shift and
she expects to stay on the job for the
duration the editorial message is clear
women are a reserve army of labor for
the war effort that the civilians are
helping the soldiers the real fighters
safeguard America and that there's a
collective spirit of self-sacrifice on
the homefront the progressive image that
the magazine bureau promoted in life and
other magazines was of bright
intelligent women recruited as soldiers
of industry Life magazine also sent
gladius Rockmore Davis to France as an
accredited us correspondent to cover
Paris at the time of the Libero of
liberation the army providing trans
bought an accommodation for life artists
she arrived there very soon after it
occurred she wore the American uniform
as you can see here in this photograph
of her being served coffee in a French
village she reported that when the
village came under counter attacked the
following day she was lucky to escape
alive bodis Roquemore Davis's paintings
of life immediately after liberation
include paintings like a mourner Paris
showing a young mother dressed in black
and her young child at a spot where
where her husband a member of the
resistance was killed others others
include Paris foot 1944 a rather dark
painting showing how shops were unable
to open due to lack of supplies and in
fact quite a few of her works are really
quite grim in contrast
in contrast her paintings schoolchildren
is much more cheery when her work was
exhibited in 1945 in the foyer of the
time-life building in New York the New
York Times critic observed she was
portraying an uncertain frightened City
and only the children seemed nourished
and it is everything else had a furtive
unreal look about it in those uncertain
days before the Ryan was crossed we turn
now to Lee Miller she was an accredited
us correspondent working for British
Vogue in the chaos of war Miller
attached herself to various US army
divisions and her photographs document
the reclaiming of France and other
locations in Europe her reports for the
British and the American Legion editions
of Vogue in September 1944 included
images like this one surgeon and an
assist 44th evac hospital showing a
medical team behind Omaha Beach in
Normandy using the rigged up equipment
typical of field surgery's she was
portraying broken injured bodies but
what's interesting about this image is
that her soft focus photography and
lacking a central focus implies but does
not unduly 12 on the injured subject it
was a remarkably restrained photograph
whereas other American media outlets
were deliberately graphic in order to
maintain public support for the wall
when she arrived in Paris soon after its
liberation she went to the chastisement
of some French collaborators the initial
punishment before the trial was to shave
their heads she provided Vogue readers
with on the spot visual and textual
accounts of life in post-liberation
Paris and then the progress of war and
by the third by the 30th of april
nineteen forty-five she'd reached Decker
she was present to photograph
she was present to photograph soldiers
looking with horror through the open
doors of a railway carriage at deceased
prisoners and in doing so she abandoned
her earlier style of restraint from
there Lee Miller and fellow photographer
David Sherman went on to Munich arriving
there on the first of May they found the
170 9th regiment at Hitler's house and
as she said in a letter to her editor i
was living in Hitler's private apartment
when his death was announced her vogue
story Hitler alia about the incident
appeared in July in August 1945 and it
included this photograph taken by David
Sherman of Lee Miller in Hitler's birth
so what of the British and the American
approaches both countries employed
employed far fewer women than men as
official war artist but how they went
about commissioning the art differed to
the British by the wac ran a highly
centralized war artist program in which
the focus for women artists was on the
home front in a war that was also being
fought on their own soil whereas most of
those male artists they commissioned
produced work with subjects that tended
to relate to frontline and behind the
front of subjects the American approach
in contrast was very different it was
highly decentralized and almost highly
sorry it was highly decentralized and
almost wholly privatized but ironically
for women artists this meant their range
of subjects was broader and it included
active zones of warfare in Europe only
at the war's end did the British finally
send two women artists into Germany to
record life there post-war life and the
conditions there Doris inkosan based in
Brussels went to Belsen and then Mary
Kessel to the bergen-belsen to place
displaced persons camp both produced
shocking images of the atrocities of
narcissism including as you see here
Zinka sins Belson and then castles notes
from the Belson cab Life magazine did
not send women photographers there
so these two nations Britain and America
linked politically and economically
operated quite differently in relation
to the employment of war artists and
women in particular they were two boats
rowing side by side but not meeting up
thank you